Most people think liver disease equals alcohol. It doesn't. Fatty liver disease is rising. It can be genetic but not always. It's often silent. But in many cases, if caught early enough, it can be reversible. So why haven't we heard more about it? Today I'm speaking with Sharon Verma,
大多数人认为肝病等于酗酒。其实并不是。脂肪肝发病率正在上升。它可能是基因引起的，但也不总是这样。它通常是静默的。但在许多情况下，如果发现得够早，它是可以逆转的。那为什么我们没听过更多关于它的消息呢？今天我采访的是莎伦·维尔马（Sharon Verma），
an NHS health coach whose father died from the disease and who has made it her life's mission to make sure other families don't learn about it too late. Hope you find it so useful. If you do, please like, comment. share and subscribe for more. Hi, it doesn't a welcome along, Sharon Verma, to the podcast. Hi, Sharon. Hello. Lovely to have you here and thank you for staying in touch since we met at an in-person event.
她是一位NHS（英国国民健康体系）健康教练，她的父亲因这种疾病去世，她将确保其他家庭不会为时已晚才了解到这种病作为自己的人生使命。希望你会觉得这期节目很有用。如果是的话，请点赞、评论、分享并订阅以获取更多内容。嗨，欢迎来到本期播客，莎伦·维尔马。嗨，莎伦。你好。很高兴你能来，也谢谢你自我们在一次线下活动中相遇以来一直保持联系。
Just about six months ago probably it was, wasn't? Yeah, it was about six months ago where we met at the event. And I love talking with you, but I also love learning and that's why I've invited you on the podcast because you were telling me about something that I have never, heard of before and I would wager that probably lots of people haven't heard about before and I think it sounds quite important so I thought we'd do a little bit of public information could you tell us what you are now kind of an expert in so I specialize in something called what used to be called non-acolic fatty liver disease but the name has now changed to metabolic dysfunction associated steostatic liver disease.
大概也就是六个月前吧，对吧？是的，大约六个月前我们在那个活动上相遇。我喜欢和你交流，我也喜欢学习，这就是为什么我邀请你来参加播客，因为你告诉我一些我以前从未听说过的事情，我敢打赌很多人也都没听说过，而且我觉得这听起来非常重要，所以我想我们应该做一点公众科普，你能告诉大家你现在可以说是哪个领域的专家吗？所以我专注于一种以前被称为非酒精性脂肪性肝病（non-alcoholic fatty liver disease）的疾病，但这个名称现在已经改成了代谢功能障碍相关脂肪性肝病（metabolic dysfunction associated steatotic liver disease）。
Now, liver disease affects one in five people in the UK, and it's asymptomatic. So you could easily dismiss this. You may feel fatigued. Maybe you have maybe a dull aches, things that you could easily dismiss. And it's not always picked up in the routine blood tests. Sometimes it may be picked up so your ALT levels may be high,
现在，英国五分之一的人口都受肝病影响，而且它是无症状的。所以你很容易忽视这一点。你可能会感到疲劳。也许你会有隐痛，这些都是你很容易忽视的症状。而且它并不总能在常规血液检查中被检测出来。有时候它可能会被检测到，所以你的ALT（谷丙转氨酶）水平可能会很高，
so your doctor might check that. But more often than not, because our liver is so resilient, it will carry and work in a way even when it's inflamed. And that's when problems start to occur, but it's not spoken about enough. No, let's really go back to basics. What are ALT levels and what does our liver do for us? So an ALT is when your liver is inflamed, it's almost like a stress hormone or protein that gets delivered into the bloodstream.
所以你的医生可能会检查这一点。但更多时候，由于我们的肝脏非常有韧性，即使在发炎时它也会继续运转和工作。而问题就是在这个时候开始出现的，但关于它的讨论还远远不够。不，让我们真正回到基础。什么是ALT水平，我们的肝脏为我们做了什么？所以ALT是指当你的肝脏发炎时，它有点像一种应激激素或蛋白质被释放到血液中。
And when that's elevated, so say, for example, your reading is coming up quite a high, So say it's gone over 35, your doctor may see it and think, oh, okay, it's a little bit abnormal, but it's fine. We'll do another check. But if it's consistently high, then your doctor should really go and do a ultrasound and see the texture of your liver and see if there are any fatty deposits. Because the sooner you catch it, the easier it is to reverse. I see. So in the early stages, it's something that you can reverse. It is. Absolutely. progresses, then it sounds like the liver gets less plastic, more rigid and scarred.
当这个指标升高时，比方说，你的读数相当高，比如超过了35，你的医生可能会看到它并心想，哦，好吧，这有点异常，但没关系。我们再做一次检查。但如果它持续偏高，那么你的医生真的应该去给你做一个超声波检查，看看你肝脏的质地，看看是否有任何脂肪沉积。因为你越早发现它，就越容易逆转。我明白了。所以在早期阶段，这是可以逆转的。是的。绝对可以。如果病情恶化，听起来肝脏就会失去弹性，变得更加僵硬并产生瘢痕。
The way to look at the think of your liver, it's a nice, soft texture. When you have a fatty liver, you'll have fatty deposits and the liver will become inflamed. If you cannot calm down that inflammation and say, for example, it progresses to from a mild fatty liver to moderate and then severe, it will start to scar and that leads to something called liver fibrosis. Now, liver fibrosis has four stages. It's known as F0 to F4. F0 to F2 is reversible, so you can stop it. When it gets to F3F4, you cannot stop the scarring in terms of going to liver cirrhosis. You can stop this up and get into cirrhosis, which is end stage liver disease, but you cannot reverse the scarring at that point. When you get to liver cirrhosis, the shape of the liver has now changed. And there are two types. So you've got a decompensated liver. or you'll have a compensated liver. If you have liver cirrhosis and your liver is compensated, your body is still functioning as it should.
要想理解肝脏，你可以这样想：它原本应该是一种漂亮的、柔软的质地。当你患有脂肪肝时，你会有脂肪沉积，肝脏会发炎。如果你无法平息这种炎症，比方说，它从轻度脂肪肝发展到中度，然后是重度，它就会开始产生瘢痕，这就导致了一种叫做肝纤维化的疾病。现在，肝纤维化有四个阶段。被称为F0到F4。F0到F2是可逆的，所以你可以阻止它。当它发展到F3、F4时，你就无法阻止它发展为肝硬化了。你可以阻止它进一步恶化为肝硬化——也就是终末期肝病，但在那个阶段你无法逆转瘢痕。当你到达肝硬化阶段时，肝脏的形状已经改变了。并且有两种类型。所以你会有代偿失调的肝脏，或者你会有一个代偿性的肝脏。如果你患有肝硬化，但你的肝脏是代偿性的，你的身体仍然在按应有的方式运转。
Our liver is so loyal or so resilient, it will keep working away. If it is decompensated, that's where your liver is struggling, and you will know about it. You will have yellowing of the skin and eyes. You will have severe itching. You will have fluid buildup. You will maybe hallucinate. You will lose muscle mass.
我们的肝脏是如此忠诚或极具韧性，它会一直坚持工作。如果是代偿失调的，那就是你的肝脏在苦苦挣扎，你会明显感觉到。你的皮肤和眼睛会变黄。你会感到剧烈瘙痒。你的体内会有液体积聚。你可能会出现幻觉。你会失去肌肉质量。
And at that point, your stages are quite bleak. You're either looking at a liver transplant if you're lucky, or sadly, it will end in death. So for me, due to my personal experience with it, it's really important, A, to get the word out, and B, to get people talking about their liver, getting people to understand how vital this organ is. It's just as vital as the heart. And the way to think about your liver is a bit like the head of an orchestra, the conductor. If it's doing, you know, if he's like doing his thing properly, everything's going to be in sync. You know, the musicians are going to be all playing a nice tune.
而在那个阶段，你的情况就相当暗淡了。如果你幸运的话，你面临的要么是肝移植，或者可悲的是，它将以死亡告终。所以对我来说，由于我对此的个人经历，非常重要的一点是：A，把这个消息传出去；B，让人们开始谈论他们的肝脏，让人们了解这个器官是多么至关重要。它和心脏一样至关重要。要想理解肝脏，它有点像乐队的指挥。如果他在正常地做好他的本职工作，一切都会合拍。你知道，音乐家们都会演奏出动听的旋律。
It's the same thing with our organs. If the liver's working well, all the organs will function. If the liver is struggling, then your other organs will struggle too. Okay, all right. So it's the kind of, it just quietly ticks away and does what it does. It's incredible. Yeah. And as you were speaking, I was thinking, oh, the itching, that reminds me.
我们的器官也是如此。如果肝脏运转良好，所有器官都会正常运转。如果肝脏苦苦挣扎，那么你的其他器官也会苦苦挣扎。好吧，好的。所以它是一种，它只是默默地滴答作响，做好它该做的事。这太不可思议了。是的。而且在你说话的时候，我在想，哦，瘙痒，这让我想起了。
When I was pregnant, that was something that you really needed to look out for. Because I think livers can flare up during pregnancy. During pregnancy, yeah, yeah, that's right. And then the cirrhosis I have heard about, I'd heard about before, but linked to alcohol. And fatty liver disease is something different to that, isn't it? It is. Fattie liver disease is the first stage. So you have a healthy liver, that liver then turns into a fatty liver, that then goes to fibrosis. And then when it gets a cirrhosis, that's where there's nothing you can do about it then.
我怀孕的时候，那是你需要特别注意的事情。因为我认为肝脏在怀孕期间会发作。怀孕期间，是的，是的，没错。然后肝硬化我听说过，以前就听说过，但它和酒精联系在一起。而脂肪肝是不同于那的一种疾病，对吧？是的。脂肪肝是第一阶段。所以你有一个健康的肝脏，这个肝脏接着变成脂肪肝，然后发展成纤维化。当它发展到肝硬化时，那就是你对此无能为力的时候了。
Which is why when you're first diagnosed with liver disease, say, for example, you're at the doctors, oh, you've got mild fatty liver disease, go and lose some weight. That is the first advice you will be given. Go and lose some weight. But it's not helpful because you can go onto any kind of diet thinking, I will lose some weight. But what research has shown and what the evidence shows is the Mediterranean style approach is the most, you know, the best approach to help somebody reverse fatty liver disease. Okay, so you might think, well, I'll have small a portions of my chips or smaller portions of my of my curries that might be laced with ghee or whatever or smaller portions of my deep fried food and that will help me lose weight which it will
这就是为什么当你第一次被诊断出患有肝病时，比方说你在医生那里，“哦，你得了轻度脂肪肝，去减减肥吧。”这是你得到的第一个建议。去减减肥吧。但这并没有什么帮助，因为你可以采用任何种类的饮食方法，心想：我会减掉一些体重。但研究和证据表明，地中海风格的饮食方法才是帮助人们逆转脂肪肝的最好方法。好吧，所以你可能会想，那我少吃一点薯条，或者少吃一点可能加了酥油或其他东西的咖喱，或者少吃一点油炸食品，这能帮我减肥，确实会这样，
but it won't necessarily impact on your liver okay okay and how did you come to have such a professional and personal interest in this Sharon so my dad was diagnosed in early 2001 so I would have been about mid-20s and at that point he had a dull ache on the side of his abdomen he ignored it for quite a while until he couldn't ignore it anymore so he went to a and e and there the doctors thought it's probably his appendix but when they checked further they found out he's actually got liver disease so he had a fatty liver and when they told him he's got liver disease his response was liver disease i don't drink alcohol and they said look go and see your doctor your doctor will explain it so the doctor said to him yes he's got a liver disease go and lose some weight
但这不一定会对你的肝脏产生影响。好吧，好吧。莎伦，你究竟是怎么对这个领域产生如此专业和个人的兴趣的呢？所以我的父亲在2001年初被确诊，当时我大概二十岁出头，那时他的腹部侧面有一种隐痛。他忽略了很长一段时间，直到再也无法忽视它，于是他去了急诊室（A&E）。那里的医生认为这可能是他的阑尾炎，但经过进一步检查，他们发现他其实得了肝病。所以他患有脂肪肝，当他们告诉他得了肝病时，他的反应是：“肝病？我不喝酒啊！”他们说：“听着，去找你的医生吧，你的医生会向你解释的。”所以医生对他说：“是的，你得了肝病，去减减肥吧。”
And they gave him a booklet, but no one even thought to ask, can this man read? He couldn't. He couldn't read or write English. And so when he told us, I've got liver disease, we dismissed it. Because we said, Dad, there's no way you've got liver disease. You don't drink alcohol. This liver disease only happens to people who can't handle the drink. You don't even drink.
他们给了他一本小册子，但没有人想到去问一句：这个人识字吗？他不识字。他既不会读也不会写英文。所以当他告诉我们“我得了肝病”时，我们并没有当回事。因为我们对他说：“爸，你绝对不可能得肝病。你不喝酒。这种肝病只会发生在那些管不住酒瘾的人身上。你甚至都不喝酒。”
But it's only after I spoke to the doctor that I understood, this is actually down to his diet, his diet and his lifetime. And he has to lose some weight. And so Dad's method of weight loss was, I will have an apple for breakfast. I will go on long walks. I'll have my main like chapati and curry in the evening and then that will work. And yeah, he lost weight, but he lost muscle mass. He didn't lose the fact that he need to lose. So by the time a year later he goes to get his liver scanned, he's then told your liver's now progressed to liver fibrosis. Again, go lose some weight. There wasn't any thorough checking being
但直到我和医生谈过之后我才明白，这其实归咎于他的饮食、他的饮食习惯和他的生活方式。他必须减掉一些体重。所以爸爸减肥的方法是：我早餐吃一个苹果。我去进行长途散步。我晚上吃主食——恰巴提（印度薄饼）和咖喱，这样就会有效了。是的，他体重减轻了，但他失去的是肌肉质量。他并没有减掉他需要减掉的脂肪。所以在一年后他去扫描肝脏时，他被告知你的肝脏现在已经发展为肝纤维化了。同样地，“去减减肥吧”。并没有进行任何彻底的检查
done or monitoring being done until he got to liver cirrhosis. Now when he got to liver cirrhosis, he was told, oh, don't worry, you know, you probably need about two, three years until you need a transplant. That wasn't the case for him. His liver started to deteriorate very quickly. So his liver became decompensated. So dad had acetes, which is fluid buildup in his abdomen, but he would resemble, say, a pregnant woman. It would be that much. And he would have to go to the hospital. He'd be admitted. And a doctor would have to insert a needle about that big into his abdomen. He'd lay still for about eight to nine hours for the fluid to be drained and at first this was being done monthly it then went to bi-weekly it then went to weekly and then it was every other day and my brother and
或监测，直到他发展到肝硬化。现在当他发展到肝硬化时，有人对他说：“哦，别担心，你知道的，你可能还需要两三年才需要做移植手术。”但对并非如此。他的肝脏开始恶化得非常快。所以他的肝脏变成了代偿失调的。因此爸爸有了腹水，也就是腹部液体积聚，但他看起来就像一个孕妇。腹部鼓起就是那么大。他不得不去医院。他住院了。医生不得不将一根大约那么大的针插入他的腹部。他得躺着一动不动大约八到九个小时来排出积液。起初这是一个月一次，后来变成两周一次，接着变成一周一次，然后变成每隔一天一次。我和我哥哥
i you know we could see he's in he's in trouble here so we were calling kings college hospital every single day because they are the most renowned hospital for liver disease patients we didn't know when dad was diagnosed but by time you know it came to dad nearing his end we then found out where he should have been. And when he finally did get to King's Hospital, we were like, oh, just take our liver. And the doctor's like, that's not how it works. One, we need to make sure that your dad's liver is at a point where we can offer him a transplant. Two, we need to make sure if you're healthy enough to have, you know, to give your liver to your dad. And, you know, there's so much more to it. We can't just open you up and give half your liver. And then sadly, dad slipped into a coma
（你知道的）能看出他有麻烦了。所以我们每天都给伦敦国王学院医院打电话，因为他们是治疗肝病患者最著名的医院。在爸爸确诊时我们并不知道这一点，但到了爸爸临终前，我们才发现他本该去那里。当他终于到达国王学院医院时，我们就像是：“哦，把我们的肝切给拿去吧。”但医生却说：“事情不是这样的。第一，我们需要确保你爸爸的肝脏已经达到了我们可以为他提供移植手术的程度；第二，我们需要确保你的身体是否足够健康，可以把你的肝脏捐给你爸爸。”你知道的，事情远比这复杂得多。我们不能直接剖开你然后把你的肝分一半给你。然后可悲的是，爸爸陷入了昏迷，
because his liver started to release toxins into his body. And then eight weeks after he turned 60, he passed away. I'm so sorry to hear that. And that is so young. You know, I lost my dad at 71 and I consider that young. But, you know, for you to lose your dad when you were a young woman, I think before you had children as well. Yeah, before I got married.
因为他的肝脏开始向体内释放毒素。在他60岁生日后八周，他去世了。听到这个消息我很难过。而且他太年轻了。我父亲在71岁时去世，我都觉得他很年轻。但是，你作为一个年轻女性就失去了父亲，我想当时你甚至还没生孩子。是的，在我结婚之前。
It's really bitter. It's a bittersweet because, I've got this, you can almost call it a black cloud over my head thinking, I'm now helping people reverse fatty liver disease, but I wasn't able to save him. And it's a guilt that I know I shouldn't have, but I do have. Absolutely. We can only do what we do with the knowledge we've got at the time, right?
这真的很苦。这是一种苦乐参半的感觉，因为我身上仿佛背负着一块乌云，心想：我现在正在帮助人们逆转脂肪肝，但我却没能救我父亲。这种内疚感我知道我不该有，但它确实存在。完全是这样。我们只能凭当时的知识做我们能做的事，对吧？
And this is why this kind of public information is so important because actually people will learn about liver, we'll perhaps learn about this fatty liver name, although they've changed that now. Could you remind us the new name and get really slowly for us so that we can really hear the words? Abbreviation is known as mazzled, but the actual wording is metabolic dysfunction associated steostatic liver disease. Okay, but you might still hear it called fatty liver disease. your doctor may call it Nathold, which is non-alcoholic fatty liver disease. N-A-F-L-D, which is what it used to be called.
这就是为什么这种公众科普如此重要，因为实际上人们会了解肝脏，也许会了解脂肪肝这个名字，尽管他们现在已经改名了。你能提醒我们新名字是什么吗？请慢慢地为我们说，好让我们能真正听清这些发音。这个缩写被称为MAZLD，但实际的全称是代谢功能障碍相关脂肪性肝病。好的，但你可能还是会听到它被称为脂肪肝。你的医生可能会叫它NAFLD，也就是非酒精性脂肪性肝病。N-A-F-L-D，这就是它以前被称为的名字。
But now they changed it to muzzled. And it feels like it should have been a simpler name, but I feel like they've made it more complicated. Yeah. But there is a reason why they've done that, and I understand why they've done that, because there's a real stigma around liver disease. You tell anyone, I've got, you know, I have an issue with my liver. First thing people think of is alcohol. And I hold my hand up.
但现在他们把它改成了MAZLD。感觉它本该是一个更简单的名字，但我觉得他们把它弄得更复杂了。是的。但他们这样做是有原因的，我理解他们为什么这么做，因为围绕肝病存在着真正的耻辱感。你告诉任何人：“我有，你知道的，我的肝脏出了点问题。”人们想到的第一件事就是酒精。我举手承认。
I was one of those people before dad was diagnosed. And that's the start of reality of liver disease. You know, it's not spoken about just enough. It's got the stigma behind it. People feel like it's their fault. It's not, it can happen to anyone. Yeah. And yeah, it is the alcohol.
在爸爸确诊之前，我就是那些人之一。这就是肝病现实的开端。你知道，人们对它的谈论还不够多。它背后带有这种耻辱感。人们觉得这是他们自己的错。其实不是，这可能发生在任何人身上。是的。而且确实是酒精。
And it's similar to pancreatitis, right? Because you think, oh, pancreatitis, that's often alcohol. But actually this is, this is not that. And, you know, like you said, your dad didn't drink. So it definitely wasn't that. Do you know when you look at family history, was anyone in his family struggling with this, even if you maybe didn't realize at the time?
这类似于胰腺炎，对吧？因为你会想，“哦，胰腺炎，那通常是酒精引起的。”但实际上这个不是这样的。而且，就像你说的，你父亲不喝酒。所以绝对不是那个原因。你知道，当你回顾家族史时，他的家人中是否有人也在与此抗争，即使你当时可能没有意识到？
Yeah, well, funn't you say funny enough, but after Dad passed away, we then found out that Dad's dad had liver, a fatty liver as well. So it's obviously genetics in my family. But we never, I never knew my granddad had a fatty liver. You know, had we have known Grandad had that, then maybe we would have been more aware of it from, you know, when my dad was diagnosed, but we weren't aware.
是的，说来也巧，在爸爸去世后，我们后来发现我爷爷也有肝脏问题，也有脂肪肝。所以这显然是我家族的基因。但是我们从来——我从来不知道我爷爷有脂肪肝。你知道，如果我们早知道爷爷有这个病，那么也许从我爸爸确诊开始，我们就会对它有更多的意识，但我们当时并不知情。
And is it, is it only with hindsight that they were like, oh yeah, he always was a bit yellow and he did always have sort of yellow whites of his eyes? Or did he always, was he already getting treatment for his liver when he was alive? He used to live in Nairobi, Kenya, and apparently he was getting treated there, but he never told his children or his grandchildren. It was something he kept to himself. But had they have actually just explained what was happening with him, it would have educated the whole family. And that's what's lacking.
而且，只有在事后诸葛亮的情况下，他们才会觉得，“哦，是的，他以前总是有点发黄，他的眼白也总是那种发黄的颜色吗？”或者他生前就已经在接受肝脏治疗了吗？他以前住在肯尼亚内罗毕，显然他在那里接受过治疗，但他从未告诉过他的孩子或孙子孙女。这是他藏在心里的一件事。但如果他们当时真的解释了在他身上发生了什么，那就会教育整个家族。而这正是所缺少的。
Even now, the education isn't there. Even now, like, you know, I've been part of the NHS for about three years now. And I've seen firsthand how liver patients are being let down. I've seen how liver patients are told, oh, yeah, just go lose some weight. But there's no help behind it. You know, there's no follow-up.
即使在今天，这种教育也是缺失的。即使现在，就像，你知道的，我在NHS工作大约三年了。我亲眼目睹了肝病患者是如何被辜负的。我看到肝病患者被告知：“哦，是的，去减减肥吧。”但背后没有任何帮助。你知道的，没有任何随访。
There's no, okay, you know what, come back in six months. Let's read your blood. Let's go and make sure you're getting your scans done. there have been times where a case has been sent to me saying, this is a fatty liver patient, please help them. So when I've called them, I've been, oh yeah, your doctor sent through the referral. I can see you've been diagnosed with fatty liver disease. And the patient is, I haven't got a fatty liver.
没有那种，“哦，你知道吗，六个月后再来。让我们化验一下你的血。让我们去确保你做了扫描。”曾几何时，有些病例被转介给我，说：“这是一个脂肪肝患者，请帮帮他们。”所以当我给他们打电话时，我发现：“哦，是的，你的医生发来了转诊单。我可以看到你被诊断出患有脂肪肝。”而患者的反应是：“我没有脂肪肝啊。”
What are you talking about? No one's told me. And that is, the change has to start. We need to see change within the NHS, for sure. Absolutely. And with genetics and the way heritability works, how's your liver, Sharon? My liver so far is so good. So far, so good.
“你在说什么？没人跟我说过。”这种情况，这种改变必须开始。我们必须看到NHS内部发生改变，这是肯定的。绝对的。从遗传学和遗传方式来看，莎伦，你的肝脏怎么样？到目前为止，我的肝脏非常好。目前一切都很好。
I had a liver scan done with the British Liver Trusks. They do something called The Love Your Liver Road Show. There are charity, is self-funded. So I went along, had my liver checked. And the synographer said to me, you know, your fatty range is fine. Your liver stiffness is fine. Because we know that your dad died from this, you cannot be too relaxed with your diet because your likelihood of getting it has, you know,
我在英国肝脏信托基金会（British Liver Trust）做过肝脏扫描。他们做了一项名为“关爱你的肝脏巡回展”（The Love Your Liver Road Show）的活动。他们是一个慈善机构，资金是自筹的。所以我去了，检查了我的肝脏。超声医师对我说：“你知道的，你的脂肪指标在正常范围内。你的肝脏硬度正常。由于我们知道你父亲死于这种病，你绝不能对自己的饮食掉以轻心，因为你患病的几率已经……
is increased tenfold. So you need to make sure you're doing everything you can, within reason, to make sure that you don't develop this disease. And so sometimes I can become quite overfocus with my health and become quite anxious about, is it going to harm my liver? Am I okay to have this? And I know that I shouldn't be doing that, but it's just always at the back of my mind that,
增加了十倍。所以你必须确保在合理范围内尽你所能，确保自己不会患上这种疾病。”所以有时我对自己的健康会变得过于专注，并对“这会损害我的肝脏吗？我吃这个没问题吧？”感到相当焦虑。我知道我不应该这样做，但它总是萦绕在我的脑海里，
Sharon, you might develop this and you don't want your children to go through what you've been through, you know, with your dad. You don't want them to see that decline in somebody's health. and, you know, so I try and make a conscious effort to do whatever I can to support my liver health. Amazing. And actually it is incredibly difficult to watch someone become very unwell, to become frail. It's distressing, you know, and someone that was previously very strong and capable to then not even be able to do things like stand up or wash or walk to the toilet.
“莎伦，你可能会得这个病，你不想让你的孩子们经历你和你父亲一起经历过的事情。”你不想让他们看到一个人的健康状况那样衰退。所以，你知道的，我努力有意识地尽我所能去支持我的肝脏健康。太棒了。事实上，看着一个人变得非常不健康、变得虚弱，这是一件极其痛苦的事情。这令人痛苦，你知道的，一个以前非常强壮、有能力的人，后来甚至无法做诸如站立、洗澡或走到厕所这样简单的事情。
And you said that your dad had lost so much weight. You gave us a really powerful example of that before we recorded. Would you ride us through that? Yeah, so Dad was in hospital. He just had his, a CT drained. And he was like, I can't find my watch. I'm like, Dad, it's okay, we'll find it. He said, no, no, I was wearing it.
你提到你爸爸瘦了很多。在我们录音之前，你给我们举了一个非常震撼的例子。你能为我们重现一下那个情景吗？好的，当时爸爸在住院。他刚刚抽了腹水。他说：“我找不到我的手表了。”我说：“爸，没关系，我们会找到的。”他说：“不，不，我戴着它呢。”
I can't find it. And we were searching away, and then he just, we could hear something. And his watch had basically gone from his wrist all the way up to his shoulder. Now, this is a man who used to be very built to the point where his wrist and his watch used to be quite snug on his wrist. And that same watch was now on his shoulder. And that just shows how much muscle he had lost, how much weight he had lost, he'd become a former shell of himself. When I think back to it, it's really heartbreaking. It's harrowing, isn't it? And when we're thinking about trauma work, that's one of the kind of bumps in the road that might keep kind of tripping you,
“我找不到它了。”我们在四处寻找，然后我们突然听到了一些声音。他的手表基本上从他的手腕一路滑到了他的肩膀上。现在，这是一个曾经体格非常健壮的人，以至于他的手腕和手表戴在手腕上时曾经非常贴合。而同一块手表现在却戴在他的肩膀上。这恰恰说明了他失去了多少肌肉，失去了多少体重，他已经变成了过去自己的一个空壳。每当我回想起这件事，我真的感到心碎。这太悲惨了，对吧？当我们考虑创伤治疗时，那是可能会不断绊倒你的那些路障之一，
tripping you up. And it stays with you, you know, you can't, I mean, yes, people say time heals. It does in a way, in terms of you get used to your new normal, but I will never ever forget the pain he went through and what we've been through. Yeah. Well, thank you for talking to us about this and for sharing it. I know it's really challenging.
它会一直伴随着你，你知道的，你无法……我是说，是的，人们说时间能治愈一切。在某种程度上确实如此，就习惯新常态而言，但我永远、永远不会忘记他所遭受的痛苦以及我们所经历的一切。是的。好吧，谢谢你和我们谈论这些并分享这些。我知道这真的很难。
Do you talk to your children about their granddad? Yeah, I tell him stories about their granddad, what he liked, what he didn't like. You know, he was such a jolly character that I try and keep his memory alive. And the girls know why I do what I do now. Because my youngest one was like, you know, what is liver disease? Why do you talk about it so much?
你会跟孩子们谈论他们的爷爷吗？会的，我经常跟他们讲爷爷的故事，他喜欢什么，不喜欢什么。你知道的，他是一个非常开朗的人，所以我努力让他的记忆长存。现在的女孩们也知道我为什么要做这些。因为我小女儿曾问我，什么是肝病？你为什么总提起它？
And I was like, well, you know, this is what took your granddad. So if I can help one family out there to not go through what we've gone through, that's a huge win. Yeah, absolutely it is. And let's go right back to basics. Can you tell us where is our liver? Where would we find that in our body? And if we were getting some liver gripe, I seem to remember when I've had hangers,
我说，嗯，你知道的，这就是带走你爷爷的东西。所以，如果我能帮助外面的某一个家庭免于经历我们所经历的痛苦，那就是巨大的胜利。是的，绝对是这样。让我们回到最基础的问题。你能告诉我们我们的肝脏在哪里吗？在我们的身体里去哪里找它？如果我们的肝区有些不适，我好像记得当我饿过头的时候，
was in the past, it's like that sort of dull ache on the back. Like, go just through that. So on the right side, you know where underneath the rib cage, the very bottom part, if you were to put your hand along there, where your hand covers, the area that covers, that's where our liver is sitting. I'm just doing it now, giving myself a little feel under my ribs. Okay. I mean, you know, it's huge.
过去常常是那种背部的钝痛。就像，简单说说看。所以就在右侧，你知道肋骨下方，最底部的位置，如果你把手放在那里，你的手覆盖的区域，就是我们肝脏所在的地方。我刚才就在这么做，在肋骨下方摸了摸。好吧。我的意思是，你知道的，它很大。
It's about 1.8 kilogram in men, 1.6, I believe, 1.5, 1.6 for women. you know, it's doing over 500 functions a day. It's a powerhouse and it doesn't get the same, I don't think it gets the same respect as the other organs. You know, everyone talks about how vital the heart is, the kidney. The liver never really gets a mention. No. It really doesn't.
男性的肝脏重约1.8公斤，女性我想是1.6公斤，1.5、1.6公斤左右。你知道的，它每天要执行500多项功能。它是一个强大的能量源，但却没有得到应有的，我认为它没有得到与其他器官同等的尊重。你知道的，每个人都在谈论心脏、肾脏有多么至关重要。肝脏却从未真正被提及。是的。确实如此。
You're right. You're right. You know, we're bucking that. You change. We're changing that narrative. So obviously, if people are diagnosed with this, we would hope that they will end up in the right part. or that they will be given the right advice, not just lose weight, but something more specific.
你说得对。你说得对。你知道的，我们正在打破这种局面。你在改变。我们正在改变这种说法。所以很明显，如果人们被诊断出患有这种疾病，我们希望他们能去对科室就诊，或者他们能得到正确的建议，而不仅仅是减肥，而是更具体的方法。
But so that people are heading in the right direction, what kind of foods would be great to include in their diet and which ones should we exclude? So you should be focusing mainly on whole foods. So it's going to be plenty of fiber, plenty of protein, reducing the ultra-processed food consumption, and just going back to basics. I think we try and overcomplicate it so much that there needs to be a Pacific diet that if you actually just pull things back and go back to basics. So you've got your vegetables on your plate, you've got some carbohydrates on your plate, you've got your protein on your plate, you've got a bit of healthy fats.
但为了让人们朝着正确的方向前进，哪些食物应该加入他们的饮食中，哪些食物我们应该排除？所以你主要应该关注天然全食物。也就是要含有充足的纤维、充足的蛋白质，减少超加工食品的摄入，回归基础。我认为我们常常把它搞得太复杂，好像必须要有一种特殊的饮食方案，但实际上如果你把事情简化并回归基础。你会发现盘子里有蔬菜，有一些碳水化合物，有蛋白质，还有一点健康的脂肪。
That's all we need. And the more variety and the more color we can add to the diet, the more our liver's going to thrive. It really struggles when we're giving it high fat, high sugar foods. And if you add alcohol to the mix, your liver then has to stop everything that is doing and eliminate the toxins from the alcohol first. So whenever I work with a fatty liver patient, I will always say, don't drink alcohol. Please try and refrain from it.
这就是我们所需要的。我们的饮食越丰富、颜色越多，我们的肝脏就会越健康。当我们给它提供高脂肪、高糖的食物时，它真的很难应付。如果你再把酒精加入其中，你的肝脏就必须停下手头的一切工作，首先清除酒精中的毒素。所以每当我接待脂肪肝患者时，我总是会说，不要喝酒。请尽量克制。
And let's focus on, let's look at what can we add to your diet. What are you having now that you think actually you could actually add a little bit more of? You know, what are you maybe not having more of that you can actually get done? Let's make it as simple as possible. Whether it's going to test going in as vegetable steam bags, quick, easy win. You know, whether it's getting frozen vegetables instead of the fresh ones, if you can't afford the fresh ones. just quick, easy wins that we can do.
让我们把重点放在，看看我们能在你的饮食中加入什么。你现在吃的东西里，有哪些你觉得其实可以稍微多吃一点？你知道的，有哪些你可能吃得不够、其实可以增加的？让我们把它做得尽可能简单。不管是买一袋袋的蒸蔬菜，这都是快速、轻松的选择。你知道的，如果你买不起新鲜蔬菜，就买冷冻蔬菜代替新鲜蔬菜。这都是我们可以采取的快速、轻松的行动。
And how can we now add more to volume to your plate? I love frozen fruit and veg. I've just been to Aldi and bought some frozen fruit now just before we met. Okay, so really in an ideal world, if someone's got this diagnosis, really we ought to be hopefully saying we're not going to be drinking anymore. But then it's sometimes I think it sounds like we're having to retrain people on how to eat well for nutrition. for fibre, not just, you know, I think one of my friends very rarely cooks and hasn't necessarily been taught to cook. Lots of people haven't, have they? I was. I was, most things from scratch,
我们现在该如何为你的盘子增加更多分量呢？我喜欢冷冻水果和蔬菜。就在我们见面之前，我刚去阿尔迪超市买了一些冷冻水果。好吧，所以在理想状态下，如果有人确诊了这个病，真的，我们希望可以说我们以后再也不喝酒了。但有时我觉得这听起来好像我们得重新教导人们如何为了营养而好好吃饭。为了纤维，而不仅仅是，你知道的，我认为我的一个朋友很少做饭，也未必有人教过她做饭。很多人都没有，对吧？我有过。我有的，大多数东西都是自己从头做起的，
but not everybody is. And, you know, certainly your dad maybe didn't have much of a hand in cooking his own foods. And I don't know, maybe he was an avid chef. But no, everything was made for him. My mom used to make everything. So I learned how to cook from mum. But yeah, you know, we also live in a culture now where we want everything very quickly. Everything's, you know, we've got it on our fingertips, whether it's Uber Eats, all the things in, but we're not really thinking about what's gone into that, what's gone into it. And you can make your own version at home quite easily as well.
但并非每个人都是如此。而且，你知道的，当然你爸爸可能不太自己做饭。我不知道，也许他是个热情的厨师。但是没有，一切都是为他做好的。我妈妈以前总是包办一切。所以我从妈妈那里学会了做饭。但是，是的，你知道的，我们现在也生活在这样一个文化中：我们希望凡事都非常快。一切都是，你知道的，触手可得，不管是优食外卖，还是各种东西，但我们并没有真正思考里面放了什么，里面到底有什么。而且你其实也很容易在家做出自己的版本。
But again, it's, I think it comes down to how educated somebody is. It also comes down to access to finances. You know, are they able to afford food? I mean, healthy food, I don't, I never, understand why healthy food is a lot more higher to buy than say something that's processed and you know it's labelled as convenience i think if we can try and change that around and that's going to come back to the government having to do something you know to help people that's the change that's needed absolutely um are any particular cultural faith you know
但话说回来，我认为这归根结底取决于个人的受教育程度。这也归根结底取决于经济条件。你知道的，他们买得起食物吗？我的意思是健康的食物，我真的，我永远不明白为什么健康食品比那些加工过、贴着便捷标签的食品要贵得多。我认为如果我们能扭转这种局面，这就需要政府采取行动来帮助人们，这才是真正需要的改变。绝对是这样的。嗯，有没有哪个特定的文化信仰，你知道的，
backgrounds more likely to experience fatty liver disease or or is it just depends on who's eating the right stuff and who isn't. I know that the South Asian population are more prone to developing it, but at the end of the day, if you are above a healthy weight range, if you've got any other metabolic conditions, whether it be type 2 diabetes or rate cholesterol levels, your likelihood of developing fatty liver disease increases, hence the name that's been changed in metabolic associated.
背景更容易患上脂肪肝，还是说这只取决于谁吃得对、谁吃得不对？我知道南亚人群更容易患上这种病，但归根结底，如果你的体重超出了健康范围，如果你有任何其他代谢状况，无论是2型糖尿病还是高胆固醇水平，你患脂肪肝的可能性都会增加，这也是为什么它被改名为代谢相关脂肪性肝病。
So I wouldn't say it's only just one set of, you know, a group of people, but it is if you have a metabolic condition, you must, must, must try and, you know, get on top of that so that you don't develop the fact you live. Okay, thank you so much. Where can people learn more about you and your work, Sharon? So you can find me on Instagram under Renourished with Sharon. I have a website at Sharon Vermeer.com.
所以我不会说它只针对某一群人，但如果你有代谢疾病，你必须、必须、必须努力去控制它，这样你就不会发展成脂肪肝。好的，非常感谢。人们在哪里可以更多地了解你和你的工作，莎朗？你可以在Instagram上通过“Renourished with Sharon”找到我。我的网站是 Sharon Vermeer.com。
And really my goal is to make people think about liver disease and bring liver to the, you know, give liver the limelight that it needs. get people talking about it, get people understanding how vital our liver is. Because if we don't have that liver functioning well, none of the other organs are going to function well. And by the year 2030, it's been predicted that liver disease will take over cardiovascular liver disease if we do not get to grips with it now. Wow. Well, then it really was important that I invited you on the podcast
说实话，我的目标是让人们关注肝脏疾病，让肝脏走入大众视野，赋予肝脏应有的关注度。让人们谈论它，让人们了解我们的肝脏是多么至关重要。因为如果我们没有运作良好的肝脏，其他任何器官都无法正常运作。据预测，到2030年，如果我们现在不加以控制，肝脏疾病将超过心血管疾病。哇。好吧，那我邀请你来播客做客真的太重要了
because we've got to do what we can do to get this, you know, to get this more amplified. And I really do appreciate. I honestly appreciate you allowing me to you know, to come onto your platform and just get this message out there. So thank you so much. Well, you're welcome. And thank you for educating me and helping me then to share this with my audience. Because, you know, I feel like I've heard about most sort of diseases and, you know, conditions. And, you know, you told me what you did.
因为我们必须尽我们所能来做到这一点，你知道的，让这个声音传播得更广。我真的很感激。我由衷地感谢你让我，你知道的，来到你的平台，把这个信息传递出去。非常谢谢你。不用谢。也谢谢你教育了我，帮助我把这些分享给我的听众。因为，你知道的，我觉得我听说过大多数种类的疾病和状况。而且，你知道的，你告诉我你所做的事情。
And I was like, say what now? So, yeah, thank you. And keep doing what you do. And let's see what we can do to not have livers overtake hearts by 2030. because that's a staggering figure. Thank you so much, Sharon. Thank you so much. What a pleasure to speak with Sharon. I love seeing her posts pop up on Instagram. So if you are not following her already, please do go and give her a little follow there. I would love to know what this has brought up for you. Is fatty liver disease something that you'd heard about before? Has this been, you know,
然后我就想，你说啥？所以，是的，谢谢你。继续做你正在做的事。让我们看看我们能做些什么，争取在2030年之前不要让肝脏病例超越心脏病。因为这是一个惊人的数字。非常感谢你，莎朗。非常感谢。与莎朗交谈真是一大快事。我喜欢看她在Instagram上发布的帖子。所以如果你还没关注她，请一定要去关注她一下。我很想知道这些对你有什么启发。脂肪肝是你以前听说过的疾病吗？这有没有，你知道的，
useful for you to learn more about livers and liver disease. I found it fascinating and some of this knowledge will will stay up here in future for when my clients might mention it. And then it helps me join up the dots and, you know, feel like I know a little bit more about stuff, which is of use to clients, but also can help me to counter fake news, right? That is really helpful when we've learned from evidence-based care, we can hear things maybe in the media, maybe even sometimes in health services that we're like, actually, I'm not sure that's right. And we can use that to help our clients to advocate for themselves and their family too. I appreciate this.
对你了解肝脏和肝疾病有所帮助？我觉得这非常迷人，其中一些知识以后会留在这里，以便我的客户提及时派上用场。这有助于我将各个点串联起来，你知道的，觉得自己对这些事情了解得更多一些，这对客户很有用，同时也能帮助我反击假新闻，对吧？当我们从循证医疗中学习到知识时，这真的很有帮助，我们在媒体中，甚至有时在卫生服务中听到一些说法时，就会觉得，其实，我不确定那是对的。我们可以利用这一点来帮助我们的客户为自己和家人发声。我很感激这一点。
It is not your average episode of the podcast, but I just thought it was really, really important to have this conversation. So I do hope that you will agree to. touched on grief today and if you would find it helpful, please do check out the Grief Collective Stories of Life, Loss Learning to Heal. It's 54 real life stories about things and people and situations that people have grieved for. It's incredibly powerful. I will let you into the secret that one of the 54 people is me. There's links in the show notes and in the description and please do, if you've read it already, please do leave me a review on Amazon or
这不是本播客普通的一集，但我只是觉得进行这次对话真的、真的非常重要。所以我真心希望你会同意。今天触及了悲伤的话题，如果你觉得有帮助，请务必查看《悲伤合集：生命、失去与疗愈的故事》。里面有54个真实的故事，关于人们为之悲伤的事物、人和情境。它具有不可思议的力量。我向你透露一个小秘密，这54个人中就包括我。节目简介和描述中都有链接，如果你已经读过了，请务必在亚马逊或
Goodreads. If you love learning more about the way that I see the world and kind of insights and nuggets from my professional life, but also my personal life at times too, or if you just really would like to support me as a creator to do the work I do for public service, for the podcast, for all these things in the media, it'd be lovely if you came and joined. My members only area, which you can do on YouTube, Captivate or Patreon or with Apple. If you want to check it out for three days on Apple, you can do that as well. We've got the backstage crew there, which is where you'll get the inner work, exclusive subscriber content episodes. And we've also got the first look where you can access the normal podcast episodes early. Thank you so much for
豆瓣上给我留个评论。如果你喜欢更多地了解我看待世界的方式，以及来自我职业生活、有时也包括我个人生活的见解和干货，或者如果你真的想支持我作为创作者，为公共服务、为播客、为媒体中的所有这些事情做贡献，欢迎你加入我的专属会员区，你可以在YouTube、Captivate、Patreon或Apple上加入。如果你想在Apple上免费体验三天，也是可以的。我们在那里拥有幕后团队，你可以在那里获得内幕工作、专属订阅者内容剧集。我们还有抢先看功能，你可以提前收听正常的播客节目。非常感谢你
being part of my world. The next episode will be along on YouTube from 10 a.m. on Saturday. and wherever you get your podcasts from 6am on Monday. Thank you again and I'll see you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
成为我世界的一部分。下一期节目将于周六上午10点开始在YouTube上播出，周日上午6点开始在你获取播客的任何平台播出。再次感谢，我们很快再见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。